Um, and now I think we're
going to do some Q and. A.
Um,
so from a teaching perspective,
how come kids who are
gamers don't seem to apply?
Uh, the sort of, uh, you know,
being okay with failure and
exploring this as to mine,
all of that in the classroom setting.
Yeah. And how can I make them do that?
Yeah. I mean there are a
couple of reasons. I mean, in,
in classroom environments there tend
to be more consequences for failure,
right? Um, I mean even at the
younger levels, um, you know, if you,
if you don't do well on something,
you will be perceived as
not being good at that.
That could affect what
group you're put in. Um,
as you get older and you fail a
tastic counts towards your grades, um,
you don't get to retake it.
I know there are a lot of schools that
are experimenting with trying to create,
um,
structures for failing that
more closely resembled games.
So schools where you can take a
test as many times as you want,
the same way you would play a level
as many times as you want to focus on
mastery rather than, you know, performance
anxiety. Um, there's a chapter,
chapter four in the book talks
about, um, those specifically,
why do only some people seem to bring
the gameful mindset to everyday life.
Um,
and at least 41% of gamers do
not bring this to everyday life.
Um, and it, it has to do with, um, uh,
whether you view games as being escapist,
um,
or whether you view them as being
a part of, of your real life.
So we have this bias.
We talk about games as being escapist
and you think you leave reality. Um,
and it helps you forget, you
know, everyday life. Um, and when,
when people are playing games, we tell
them they're wasting time, right? Um,
people who feel that way,
uh,
tend to play games more when their life
gets more stressful because they see it
as this kind of coping
mechanism the same way.
Some people drink more when life gets
stressful or they eat junk food or they
just,
um,
and so then the problems get bigger and
so then they have to play games more
cause they're more stressed out now.
Um, and it creates this downward spiral.
And that's actually the number one
predictor of like who becomes addicted to
games are people who see game
does escape this. Um, eh,
people who benefit and sort of the way
out of that seems to be people who focus
when they play games on, um,
how they're getting better.
So I played this game. I'm, I'm
getting better at, you know,
spacial intelligence or teamwork or
coordination or designing or creativity or
whatever it is.
So the really practical
answer that question is to
talk to kids about the games
they play and say,
what do you like?
What do you have to be good at
to be good at this game? Um,
order model back to them.
Wow.
You like it took you four days to finish
that level. Um, that sounds really,
but you must be somebody
who when you have a goal,
you don't give up until you really succeed
and start to help kids see that there
are real character strengths
that are part of who they are,
not just when they're playing games,
they don't have to escape reality to have
those feelings or have those strengths.
Um, so is it a whole chapter about
how you do that in, in chapter four?
Yeah. Oh No, I have the mic.
I've been talking about super better a
lot with a friend because there was just
an article in the less psychology today
about it and we thought it was cool and
we had this whole discussion about what
our power ups and what are bad guys.
And that was cool. So my
question is actually a question
from my friend who says,
please ask.
I'm curious as to how effectively people
use super better to deal with issues.
I might be concerned about
like procrastination and
mild anxiety rather than
deeply debilitating depression,
et cetera. Right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Okay. Well Sue, uh,
I'm gonna give it to you straight here.
This,
this method seems to
work better and better.
The more, uh, difficult
your challenges. Um,
so when we crunched the numbers
and people who signed up to like,
I want to lose 10 pounds, I want to
run my first five k, um, I dunno,
I'm just bored of my life.
I want to change. Um,
those people do not register a lot
of benefits and we, we, there's, um,
there's this other measurement tools
inside the system where we look at changes
and things like courage and
optimism and things like that. Um,
those people don't register
as many changes. Um,
where as people who come with
big problems, you know, I,
you know, I, I just lost a family member.
I've been diagnosed with something.
I have always suffered with anxiety.
Um, they registered the biggest changes.
So that is, I think that's important. Um,
and, and there are lots of reasons that
would make sense. Why, um, you know,
I mentioned the idea of post
traumatic growth earlier. This, the,
as I explained in the book,
the super better method at its heart.
What it seems to do is
promote posttraumatic growth.
In order to have post traumatic growth,
you have to have some kind of, you know,
serious challenge or trauma.
Now there is a version of posttraumatic
growth that does not require trauma.
It's called post static growth.
But I also talk about that in the book,
but it still requires you to do something,
but it's extremely difficult.
So running a marathon, not if
I can't, I'll marathon, um,
trying to maybe write your first
book, starting a company, um,
becoming a parent for the first time.
So positive things,
but that will really force you to,
to kind of dig deep and cultivate
that new form of shrine.
So the short version is, um, uh,
it may, it might, it might help,
but it will,
it will make a bigger difference in
the lives of people who are really
struggling with something.
So one is, you know,
and you just put it on your phone
now and hopefully you don't need it,
but maybe some,
it will help you more.
I've tried to use games as a way
of developing particular, uh,
cognitive styles.
And I've often found,
and I'll start playing a game
with the intent of who you know,
I'm going to be practicing
some cognitive skill or other,
and then I find kind of an hour has passed
and I noticed I slipped totally into
complacency and I wasn't
practicing that cognitive style.
I wasn't,
I wasn't trying the new strategy
that I had intended to try.
How do I maintain the focus required
when playing games to make sure that they
do that.
I actually do use them as that sort of
practice rather than kind of idly passing
the time.
Well that's really interesting.
I mean that's because on one hand,
I mean I would think from what I've
seen that I believe passing the time is
actually totally fine.
I mean that,
that it will do the same
thing. Um, you know,
you don't have to adopt a particular
style of game play or strategy.
What you want to do to make sure,
I mean,
so we talked about playing a
game you've never played before.
We'll make that mindset happened faster
than playing a game you played a hundred
times. So maybe it'd be
more a matter of, um,
making sure that you're exposing
yourself to different games,
different genres of games, you know, if
you've never played a certain genre to,
to, to try that sort of expand your, um,
your competency with
different kinds of games.
I would think that aspect of making sure
that you're always requiring yourself
to be learning and improving,
um, is probably, you know,
probably the most important aspect
of it. Um, but other than that,
there's not a particular, you know, just,
just make sure that it's challenging,
really challenging for you and challenge
yourself to, to learn different games.
Is this a really good way
to do that? Cool. What else
you guys pick?
So you said we should ask this
question earlier, so what,
what about what can go
wrong with violence?
Yeah, definitely. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Okay. Um, so, uh,
all of all of the stuff they're putting
in the media is hype and not to except
for, um, if you spend most
of your time playing violent,
aggressive themed games, we'll use
call of duty as an example, um,
against people you don't know online,
not in the same space.
Um,
the one negative side effect of that is
that if boost your testosterone in a way
that does not in other gameplay context,
it doesn't happen if you are playing
against people, you know, in real life.
It's like we don't have to
be in the same room with Bob,
but if I know I'm playing,
you and I were cool, um,
I'm not going to get this
sort of testosterone jack.
There's a lot of research behind
it, um, that I explain in the book.
But for now we'll just
say you're going to like,
you can get basically
testosterone poisoning is how
one researcher describes it.
Um, where, uh,
after you're done playing for
hours afterwards can make you,
um, just more hostile and your interaction
with other people, more aggressive, um,
uh, less compassion and empathy because
you're really jacked up on testosterone,
which just has that effect on
people. Um, so you know, uh,
that's why some game communities
may have a reputation for, uh,
it's kind of people get
become kind of jerks. Um,
so I recommend you know, that you spend
less than half your time doing that.
If you're going to play
a lot of these games,
make sure you spending a
significant amount of time
playing them with people you
know,
that you have to continue
to have relationships with
because that's what stops,
that's what damp dampens the testosterone.
However, I'm very open minded person.
I think people should use games to
benefit themselves however they want.
There may be people who want to
Jack up some testosterone, you know,
I'm going into have a contract negotiation
and I do want to be aggressive or uh,
I mean, you may, you may want that.
So, um, I am not to judge there.
There may be benefits to it as well.
But that is, that is the genre.
So thanks for coming back to that.
I'm curious if you've a investigating
the relationship between York on PTSD and
other work like Vanderkolk's the
body keeps the score, you know,
ideas of trauma being stored somatically.
Physically,
no, I'm not familiar with that.
But the name is very evocative.
Your body keeps the score.
Yeah, that was a new book.
The body keeps the score.
I am, I'm going to buy that.
That's great. Thank you for that.
So I was kinda curious about
the reference to motor neurons,
not knowing some of that.
It's pretty controversial a and it
only applies to sort of where motor
activities involved.
I'm kind of curious,
not knowing anything about the gaming
world and people watching these video
screens of other people playing.
How much of that is like,
you know,
actual physical activity that they can,
their motor neurons can actually
relate to versus intellectual?
Like if it's scrabble
or some boring thing.
I can look at golf and I'm always started.
Yeah, I mean I would, I would
contest the idea that it's just, I,
I know there's a, there, there are
discussions now going on about, you know,
there's sort of, there was a, it's
on the, what is it, the hype cycle.
The hype chart went into the, the
trough of disillusionment. But um,
would you do absolutely still
seemed mirror neurons even
in things, um, you know,
conversation. So if, if
I'm having, if we're,
we're close friends and you're
telling me about your day,
we do see that my brain will,
as you tell me,
your story will start to mirror
the as if it happened to me.
Um, and I don't know
that, that necessarily,
I mean you see the same kind of
emotional activation. It's not that, uh,
I feel like there's a sufficient body
of literature that this, um, that this,
that there is a sort of general um,
processing of experience
that can be in York.
That's where I,
that's where I come down on all they
know is this sort of the people are,
people are arguing about it. Um,
you know, there is, there is,
there is a strong physical
component. I mean, in terms of,
uh, I mean in, in the same way that
speed typing has, you know, a component.
I mean you have to be able to uh,
input decisions and execute decisions
very quickly through the interface.
It can be possible. It'd be part of when
you think about the, the piano example,
I mean that is probably similar playing
the piano and sort of the controls of
the video game. Um, you, you still have
to be mirroring the musicality. I mean,
you have to have the understanding
of the musicality, um,
and not just the execution
of, um, of the interface.
But, uh, so we have
time for one more maybe.
Sure. Yeah. Um, so sometimes when you're
achieving a goal and a video game,
it feels really frustrating.
Yeah. So is there a value,
positive or negative in the frustration
or is there only a value and achieving
them?
Oh, no, no, no, no. Most of the value is
in the frustration. I mean, it is, um,
the,
the value is in staying motivated and
optimistic while being frustrated.
So, you know, when we were
looking at that, that,
that what is the mindset of super
empowered, hopeful individual.
But if somebody who was highly motivated
and able and optimistic and able to
learn,
uh,
and try and be flexible and try different
strategies so that in the face of
frustration, they will continue
to engage with the obstacle. Um,
Eh, it's why I like to
play games, you know,
myself that are very challenging.
Uh, I love it when I have to,
you know, try a level a hundred
times before I get past it. Um, that,
that's where a lot of the resilience,
that seems to be one of
the most essential, nope.
What do games make us good at?
Being resilient in the face of
that kind of frustration. So,
um, yeah, don't play games that you're
good at and always winning. That's,
that's just positive emotion. Um, but
the actual positive psychology, the,
the strengths will come out of
playing games that you are bad at,
which is why we played a game that you
guys would know you went through were
surprisingly good at massive and multiple
years gravel though it was good. Um,
good. Well, good to me.
Thank you.